make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so I am kind of late to this and I
am exhausted um we just got back from
Lexington and Cleveland and it's been a
very very busy but exciting week but I
am very very tired right now
so this video will be a little bit
lackluster in comparison to the other
ones that I make but like I said I'm a
little late to this party but the
post-credits scene for a spider-man far
from home I don't know anybody who
hasn't really seen it yet and I guess
the way this comes out on on this coming
Sunday it kind of makes sense you know
that most people would have seen it by
now so I guess spoiler alert for those
who haven't there's two post-credits
scenes the first one's pretty
self-explanatory right I mean it's
basically like JK Simmons comes back he
plays J jonah Jameson Peter Parker's
identity has dumped to the world that
kind of a thing and then there's the
second post-credit scene and it's kind
of funny because a lot of people are
referencing sword and I guess to a
degree that's true but I would actually
say it's probably the Alpha Flight
initiative now that I think about it
like the Alpha Flight Program so in
Marvel Comics you've got a bunch of
different organizations right like you
have sword the sentient world
observation in response Department
you've got armor the alternate reality
monitoring I was the operative
monitoring and operational response
agency I think is what is called
basically sword monitors
extraterrestrial planets right like it
monitors space and armor monitors like
alternate realities and then you have
shield which most everybody knows
monitors earth right and all of them are
designed to be security for the planet
Earth so if like Dormammu invaded from
an alternate dimension or like some evil
version of Doctor Strange showed up from
an alternate reality then armor would
basically alert the superheroes on earth
you know whether not they'd be powerful
enough to stop him would be a whole
different discussion but the fact
remains like there's a bunch of
different organizations that serve
various purposes and even then like
there's still organizations beyond those
right you have all kinds of different
groups and things like that you got
factor 3 and you've got all kinds of
stuff out there a sword originally made
its debut back an astonishing x-men
issue number 6 I think it was by Joss
Whedon and the idea behind this was that
it was led by a woman named Abigail
brand now Abigail brand was was tasked
with leading sword because she was a
person or really like an alien more or
less who had like this spiked tongue and
she could essentially speak like a
myriad of different languages right like
every language on earth and then like
almost every language in the universe
right so she was the perfect person to
be a kind of liaison between
extraterrestrial groups and like earth
itself right because if there
like aliens who were refugees from a
different world but they don't speak
English you know a language native to
earth then like when they showed up if
if sword wasn't there then like they
would be treated as a threat right like
hence the basis behind Nick Fury calling
in for to face off against beta ray bill
so when you take that that the whole
cost of a new apply to the Marvel
Cinematic Universe you go through the
history of it right so sword was led by
Elega Abigail brand for a number of
years and in reality sword was a plot
device it was basically just the the
purpose that Joss Whedon used in order
to like bring back Colossus and like you
know one or two other characters and
then have like some guy show up who
reached all kinds of havoc and so on but
for years sword just kind of existed out
there and they had some stories right I
mean they have stories that involve them
and invoked you know their knowledge of
space and different things like that
because when Joss Whedon and John
Cassaday did astonishing x-men it was
back in 2004 right it's like following
that you went into like annihilation and
annihilation conquests and things like
that
and while sword wasn't the biggest part
of it it did but you know have some
involvement in it and so following that
you went into like all-new all-different
marvel right so you had um sword as an
organization doing its thing and hickman
even invoked it during the events of
like of the multiverse or collapse right
so like you had sword and then you had
like you had Robert de castas advanced
idea mechanics this one so forth you
were kind of working in unison and then
sword was so sort of co-opted by Robert
Acosta and aim and interns like the
multiversal Avengers but the idea behind
that was that with the multiverse will
collapse taking place sword was one of a
multitude of organizations using all
their resources to figure out what was
going on and to look into space and see
they could find the answer to it also
going they didn't and of course the
multiverse collapsed inevitably it ended
up being just like like Doctor Strange
and the molecule man and like a couple
other people who figured out what was
going on it was basically Doctor Doom
who ended up causing everything and I
just working alongside molecule man but
the fact remains following the the start
of all-new all-different marvel that
Abigail brand was basically removed as
the director of sword and she was
replaced with Carol Danvers and then
sword was was kind of wiped away in its
entirety and replaced by the Alpha
Flight Program and the reason why was
because Alpha Flight was a Canadian
superhero team right they were part of
Canada's Department H or Department K I
can't ever which one it is but they're a
basically part of Canada's like like
super top secret superhero organ
Asian thing which would have like
Vindicator and like Sasquatch and a
handful of others
I don't think Vindicator was part of the
Alpha Flight Program I think The
Vindicator program had Langston's been
like of like removed and eliminated by
the time Alpha Flight came around but
alpha fly is basically just the Canadian
superhero team and they have their small
fan base and it's really dedicated but
honestly I never really cared about
Alpha Flight and so in order to kind of
take part in like the all-new
all-different marvel marvel basically
took the Alpha Flight concept and
applied it to sword and then said now
it's the Alpha Flight Program and so
what you ended up having was like this
these huge like these huge numbers of
like Scrolls and so on who were working
in and really like a lot of humans who
were working as part of the new Alpha
Flight Program or just to say like
working inside there their base of
operations and monitoring things and so
on and so forth then he had Carol
Danvers who was leading it and under her
you had Alpha Flight which is basically
like the reconnaissance team right so
like if something popped off in space
off the flight would be the ones who
would go and they would look at it and
see what was going on that's where
things stand right now and they have for
quite some time um Carol Danvers is kind
of in a weird middle ground right
because after the events of civil war -
basically every fan in in like Marvel
Comics almost every single fan hated
Carol Danvers right because like it was
kind of okay so basically like she was
written to kill Tony Stark she was
character assassinated by Brian Michael
Bendis and so people really like hated
her character going going from there I'm
almost kind of tried to backpedal on
that and try to fix a little bit in her
stories right now actually pretty good
um but I don't remember if she's uh if
she's still in charge of the Alpha
Flight Program or not but regardless of
the situation
um in all honesty in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe I'd say that's the
direction that they're going because
those are really makes sense for the MCU
to introduce a new team or a new concept
based on like old hat stuff right I mean
Captain America sure but even when you
look at like Ironman or you look at like
spider-man or any of those characters
they're based on like modern-day
depictions of the characters right so
like if you look at Iron Man I'm sorry a
spider-man suit in spider-man far from
home it's almost identical to the suit
from like all-new all-different marvel
so it makes sense that they would
reference new events instead of old
events but at the end of the day um I
would say that the what's most likely
gonna go on here is we're gonna get the
Alpha Flight Program and that in turn is
gonna lead to the introduction of the
Fantastic Four but what they would end
up doing at least what I would do anyway
is I would have like little post-credit
scenes over the course of like a whole
bunch of movies they would just have
sword referencing like like or
alpha flight program whatever everything
like the lattice existence or like the
Silver Surfer showing up the first step
would be like an encounter with soar
with with alpha flight whatever that
program is there's a ton of things they
could do to expand their cosmic
landscape say hey like there's some die
flying out there with a helmet on
there's a zillion things that they could
do and even then like you could have a
tie-in to the larger hole right so like
if they ever decide to introduce San
Alexander write like Nova they can
basically say yeah like we know about
the Nova force released we've heard of
it and kind of set him on a mission or
whatever there's a lot of things that
they could do I mean it really like the
offers are limitless and honestly I'm so
tired I can't really even think of a
whole lot of them right now but but
nonetheless you know the opportunities
there to really expand on on the Marvel
Cinematic Universe with regards like the
cosmic landscape and like the cosmic
scope of things because you're talking
about introducing an organization that
really serves no other purpose than to
monitor space and then like tell us
what's out there in space so it opens up
like a whole new world because that's
that's that's one of the things you guys
have to keep in mind when it comes to
the Marvel Cinematic Universe I mean
like if you really just count numbers
wise like they've only ever hit like the
very tip of the tip of the tip of the
iceberg right so like we have Black
Panther and Wakanda so you can kind of
count that as one whole thing you have
the Avengers in the form of like Black
Widow Hawkeye Thor Captain America Iron
Man The Incredible Hulk
like you know and that's really kind of
in in terms in terms of the roster or
the lineup
you've got Doctor Strange you got the
Spider Man you've just got like what's
basically kind of like a hodgepodge and
a smidge mattering of characters here
and there and compare sort of like
everything that makes up the entirety of
Marvel Comics right so like just based
on not even using alternate realities or
any even anything out there in space
they can develop superheroes on earth
like forever like fur for years and
years and years I mean if they do like a
movie every two years you're talking
about like almost a hundred years before
they even began to come close to to even
touching on the possibility of an of
exploring every single hero on earth
right because there's like all of its
caliber there's like all that stuff
there there's all the x-men that means
like the entirety of the mutant
population whatever form that takes
you've got Magneto and every there's a
ton of things that they could do after
this so again I think this is really
gonna be a way for them to kind of
introduce the Fantastic Four in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and then it's
kind of go from there because in reality
if I'm the MCU if i'm Kevin Feige in
them I'm
to the the Fantastic Four before I'm
introducing the x-men and the reason why
is that while the x-men are more popular
the Fantastic Four are the original
superhero team and and like in Marvel
Comics the Fantastic Four were the means
by which Marvel introduced new
characters and teams right so like
struggling characters or haired as they
wanted to bring in and introduce to
readers they did it in the Fantastic
Four amazing spider-man number one Peter
Parker goes and tries to join the
Fantastic Four
Black Panther introduced in the
Fantastic Four the Inhumans introduced
in the Fantastic Four the x-men teamed
up with them on a multitude of occasions
because the sales were kind of slumping
and it was way to sort of try to boost
them Thor teamed up with the Fantastic
Four it's it's one of these things that
you always see happened you know Iron
Man so on and so forth everybody had
their hands in that team because they
were the first family of Marvel Comics
so I would introduce them in before I
introduced the x-men and despite the
fact that I'm a massive fan of the x-men
so um nonetheless you know again I'm
kind of late to the party here that's
just the way it goes I'll make this
video throw it out there let you guys
know at least what's going on or at
least some idea of what to expect in the
future of the MCU and yeah so with that
being said we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you guys are new here to
comment explain it make sure you guys
hit the sub button to become part of the
robb poor if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]